beyond the political realm beyond the
dnc which i can't believe i've got to
watch for another night tonight what i
do for you people
what i do the sacrifices i make look
into corporate america
this leaked yesterday was a slide from a
goodyear tires
employee presentation it described their
zero
tolerance policy their zero tolerance
policy on
expression things you can say things you
can wear
here is what the slide lists as
acceptable
expression black lives matter
or lesbian gay bisexual transgender
pride
those are the two things listed under
acceptable here's what's listed as
unacceptable
blue lives matter all lives matter
mega attire or politically affiliated
slogans or material
so far left-wing activism
good acceptable
anything even remotely patriotic
or conservative unacceptable
that's corporate america i mean just
these blue
you can't say that you support cops you
can't say you support law and order
that's no longer allowed because of
goodyear
you can't say you support all lives it
has to be only black lives not all lives
black lives
white lives are bad hispanic lives are
bad
asian lives are very very bad no one
cares about that they don't matter only
only black lives according to goodyear
magga you can't support the president
you can't even support the expression
make america great again you got to make
america worse
or you got to say america was never that
great just like andy cuomo said when he
was being
slightly more honest and nothing
political
unless it's left-wing i think
conservatives are finally waking up to
something that they
did not understand for decades for
decades
conservatives in the republican party
carried water for corporate america
they shilled for giant transnational
corporations
with no loyalty to their own country
no sense of honor or virtue they bought
into this
bs kind of
silly ein rand argument from the 1980s
that all that matters is money and we've
got to worship money
and any sense of solidarity as our
country any sense of respect
for our founding ideals and our founding
fathers and for the common good
is somehow un-american go back and read
the founding fathers go back and read
the writings of john adams thomas
jefferson
go back and george washington go james
madison go i mean we can list
all the founders go read abraham lincoln
do you know what they refer to all the
time
the common good virtue
loyalty patriotism solidarity with our
fellow citizens
when you go back and read the founding
fathers it doesn't read like an iran
novel doesn't read
like some bad russian novelist
okay we've got to come back to a sense
of what this country is
that doesn't mean we have to throw out
capitalism that doesn't mean we have to
hate businesses all of a sudden
but it does mean that we've got to get
our priorities in order
we are americans we have to love our
country we have to
we have a right we the people to assert
ourselves in politics
and if you're not going to do that in
your corporation
i don't want anything to do with you
okay goodyear by the way has not
confirmed that this was them
they haven't denied it either seems to
me like if this
weren't their slide they would have
denied it right away i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you